okay thanks for the introduction
um yeah we'll do sort of
live coding because uh there's quite
some uh code that
is involved in this so i already did
some coding
up front so i will uh show you
how we go from from notebook to the code
what decisions that we made
um how we used
a kind of architecture to
get into production as fast as possible
with also
some confidence that the code is
actually working
yeah let's share my screen have a few
slides up front
yeah so i'm working for a team tv
founder of
a company we started as a
video analysis company where we
provide online tools for sports clubs to
do
yeah the analysis of their matches and
in the last couple of years we also
worked with lot lots of data to
to make life easier of the the staff of
an uh
of a team and this talk uh is about
uh one of the tools that we built and
also about the journey
of how we how we built the tool and
where it all started
um yeah where it all started started
in the description of this talk i also
uh mentioned
joe milbury is a head of scouting
of uh northland
in denmark it's one of the biggest clubs
there
and he works also as a data scientist
there
and there's a huge community
on twitter and he's also on twitter i'm
on twitter so we met
there and someday i asked can someone
help me with a flask
application because he already built
something in a notebook
i was like well i would would like to
learn about what you build
and i can i can do some coding um
i know about flash
so i said yes i can help you and
then he sent some files because he
already started
with something from his notebook to make
it more
into components i was like yeah
we need to do some refactoring here
and today i will uh tell about uh
like the journey from the notebook
from the code that he sent me to
something that we actually run into
production on heroku
with a visualization tool on top of it
the problem that he solved is pretty
interesting a lot of
video analysis spend a lot of time
on finding right moments into the match
and it's pretty common that a coach
would say
give me all um situations
in past five matches where
for example balls on the right side of
the penalty box
and some players are at a certain
position
and video analysis has to
check well if he's lucky only five
matches but maybe even 10
so he has to spend 15 maybe 20 hours on
watching footage to find the right
situations
and idea was that we can make a tool
where we can automated
so you select a specific situation
um we will the two will find similar
situations
and that you only have to review those
an algorithm joe already built is pretty
interesting
so it's based on a
kernel density estimation so on the left
side you will see
a plot of a scatter plot of the
positions of players on the field
and that's translated into a kernel
density
estimation plot here and what he did was
use this one change this into
a huge factor and do that for every
frame
every situation in the match and use
a nearest neighbor search and try to
find similar situations like that
and the result was pretty okay
but it was really slow used a lot of
memory
and yeah it only run on on this laptop
so when i received the code we started
to
look at what is the code actually doing
and figuring out how we can improve it
code wise clean code wise
make it faster and in the
the process of getting it into
production
i mostly follow um
the onion architecture and
yeah the description tells a bit of the
story
so how to not make spaghetti code um
this one is pretty different than i
mostly see in in code so what does this
mean
uh the onion architecture the
it tells us that the domain is the most
important part of the application so in
the domain you have to the models
and the services and services like where
the magic happens and domains is
uh where the knowledge about the domain
is stored
and all the outer layers are um
yeah for example to interact with
databases or other tools or apis
and you get another layer around to
use the domain and combine all those
layers
um so that's good to know if we
go through the code that we will try to
structure all the code using this
principle
so let's look at some code i will start
with
um the original code that i
received from from joe and
yeah this is pretty interesting and i i
will try to
see what and describe what i see and and
where it belongs
in the onion architecture um
so let's start here this is he told me
that the engine
is where yeah everything happens
you see some imports are not working uh
it was pretty hard for me to
to get it running uh again
but it doesn't really matter um in this
case the first step is that
it will do some some reading
it will find the effort to read the data
and it will do some
yeah some some magic around here it will
see if frames are alive
and it also tries to to skip
some of the frames so in my opinion
that might be already part of it should
go
uh into a domain logic
but let's let's skip that for for now um
and after discussing with uh joe we find
out that
this one is actually
where the the density plots are created
so let's go there we have a prepared
frame
and yeah it was still pretty complex so
what i
try to do is create a model
of what what i
actually should um what do you call it
um a model of the the actual data
that lives in the domain so let's see
what i i did there
so in the end um there are only three
models that we need to
handle in the entire code so there's a
tracking data set
which holds all the data and
that holds all the frames and every
frame
has a frame id time stamp um
it contains all the the player
coordinates of the home team
player corners of the away team and the
accordance of the ball team
and as you can see i'm not using a
pandas data frame here
um that's uh
that's something that we really choose
for
because in this way
it's really easy to understand how those
models are related
so when i read data i need to have a
tracking data set
and that should contain the frames and
the points and i can also
uh see over here that are some
um constraints
that the data should met
so for example the x coordinate cannot
be minus lower than minus 10
and not bigger than uh plus
105 which is
the leg of a soccer pitch and also this
is the
width of the soccer page
so the first thing that we actually did
is extract
the domain models from
all this code
and it's that's pretty handy
because now we can uh talk about
uh tracking data without having to talk
about
on those data frames or any other
way of storing the data
and what we also want to do is
search some kind of search results
because we
yeah we need something and that just
contains an
idea of the frame and the
score of the the match
so that's the the first part that we
created the models and
we validated so i discussed with joe
well is this actually
how the how tracking data looks like um
this is still a bit um simplified
because in the actual world you also
have things like
a ball owning team so you know
which team owns the ball
uh if the balls alive so if it's uh
in the in the field or not
some other stuff will we just leave it
out right now
then next step would be to
um yeah find a solution to
make the algorithm faster
and the first thing i tried was
using multiprocessing
so i just took the original code and
tried to to make it faster
and in the end well we just
still had to use a lot of memory and was
still slow
so i wanted to replace it with a simpler
version
and that's
when we looked at a mooncrest
algorithm it's also called hungarian
algorithm
it's actually an assignment
algorithm so it's used for assigning
tasks to workers and why did we use
it let's see i have a
nice notebook over here
so for example we have two frames with
two players in it
first player is at position 0.0
second one at 3.4
and in the second frame they are swapped
but in our case we don't really care
which player is at what position
uh if they are from the same team you
just want to know if there is a person
at a certain position
so if we want to compare the similar i
want to calculate similarity between
those two frames
we want to calculate a distance between
those two
and in this case the first thing that we
have to do is
calculate a distance matrix or the three
okay so this is five and five so if we
go from player one um
to the player one in the second frame
there's a distance of
five five meters in this case uh from
player one and
player two in second frame that's zero
et cetera and then the mooncrest
algorithm
tries to find an optimal assignment
and in this case the optimal assignment
is
assigning player one and first frame to
player
two in second frame um player two
in the first frame to player uh
one in the second frame that's what you
see in here
and then you can use the assignment in
the distance
matrix and calculate cost
and that that's what we used to
calculate uh the similarity between
two frames um the interesting one is
that we use a
a compiled version so
um there is a package that does this in
playing python but it's it's pretty slow
and this one is a compiled version and
we can just run it
and see what's going on there
so it's taking about 45 micro seconds
uh for calculating the distance for one
frame
and of course you could say well this is
a really small frame
and it's it's kind of staged so let's do
it for
a bigger frame of elf 11
players and also add some some random
noise to it
so you can see the distance matrix will
be a bit bigger and
let's see yeah this also works fine
and it will show that it found the the
minimal
um distances between
all players so for the first player
there's a player
on this distance and it's yep i think
pretty close
uh and the total sum so the distance
between those frames
is uh the 0.08
and that's not a coincidence that is
actually
the movement like the noise that we
added
in in here
so it did a pretty good job at assigning
uh those players and let's see if it's
also
fast enough
yes it is it is so it's still really
fast
uh when it needs to calculate the
distance between
two frames okay so that's that's
interesting let's go back to the code um
another thing that we uh
run into with with this code original
code is
that it's pretty hard to test and as you
can see
uh this one is simple to test
i'm not really sure if people use for
example
pi uh test often but i do
and if you want to test it i could just
run this test
and everything is successful so what
does this tell
me when i try to create a result
so this one i'm not allowed to have a
score
lower than zero or higher than
100 so it should fill with a
value error in case the score is lower
than
uh zero and also raise an
exception when score is higher than 100
and we do some more checking over here
the same we can do for the
minecraft matcher so let's take a look
at the code
first so how does this work
we build an abstract matcher class
which will receive a reference frame
so the one that we um that we specified
and we want to find more frames that
look uh looks like it
looks similar
so we can pause it a frame and this
matcher will
with a certain calculation
will return a score so as you can see it
will
calculate the distance for the home
players uh
for the away players and also
uh for the ball because the ball is also
pretty important
and because we isolated this one
and it doesn't have any dependencies
other than the frame
it's pretty easy for us to test this
so we create one frame create another
frame
we create a minecraft matcher
um based on frame one and we pass it
another frame and of course
we cheated a little bit here because we
let it only check
the ball coordinates but yeah we can
always pass it
uh the player corners as well but this
is the most simple
test and it should
return certain scores so i can just run
it
and you'll see all tests are successful
but right now we only have created a
code for the the inner layer the domain
and there's no way to access this
because
yeah we don't have any interfaces
created yet so next step
is to create a small application layer
and this is the layer where we
pause our repository we will go into
more detail
there and also
a positive type of matcher in this case
we only have one metro so it will always
be the minecraft matcher
but we have several types of
repositories
and let's take a look at that one
let's see
interfaces uh infrastructure
so uh we can remember from the first
slide of
about the onion architecture so the
infrastructure
is like the outer layer where
we work together with external systems
like
s3 database file systems
and this one also knows about
external formatting
of files so let's go to
so if we want to read a file
and get a tracking data set we need to
have a repository
and i mostly work with some interfaces
and in python you don't really
know the concept of interfaces so just
let's just create an abstract
um base class here and this tells me
that when i create a repository it
always needs
a load method on it which accepts a data
set id
and that returns a tracking data set
and i don't really know in here
how this should be implemented but i
know for sure
it should return a tracking data set
and also for the saving i should be able
to deposit the tracking data set and
it needs to be saved so let's see how we
implemented this
for the local file system
so as you can see it implements the load
function and let's see what happens if i
change it
and i always use a rda
because it helps me working and
in this case it will tell me well i
didn't implement all abstract methods so
it tells me
i still have to implement this one
the load method
so um it is for a local repository
it's yeah the civilization is pretty
ugly
because i use pickle so when the
definition of a tracking data set would
change over time i'm not able to reuse
the stored files but
yeah for the for this uh talk it's just
a bit easier i could switch to json or
any other
civilization format but in this case i
will just use pickle
and i can load the data and save the
data
so now let's see if i can actually
create a data set
so there's a lot going on here but let's
have a look at
this one
i'll first import a metric gap passer
metrica is also a company working
in soccer analytics
it's kind of a competing
company but i have really good contact
with
the cto of the company we also work
together on cloppy
so uh yeah kind of friends there
and they are one of the
companies that provide open data so they
provide tracking data
uh that you can play around with and uh
create your algorith
algorithms on top of it and that's
that's really awesome
um i think they are the only actually
the only company
that provides open tracking data
so that's great so if you want to fill
the
local repository you will use the metric
parser
posit some files and
in the end it will return a data set and
then we will store it in our
local repository let's see what happens
there
um fill logo
well that went pretty fast
so um yeah let's see
the passing took like a second
which is totally fine and then writing
it to her whole story
was also pretty fast and then we can see
over here we start in the process
and there's a the old pickle file i can
just remove it
run it again
and there it is okay
so that's that's great
um and we can also start on on s3
so you can do the same and fill the
s3 repository and you will notice that
it looks
really similar we also have
the metric cad parser read file
and store it to s3
this takes a little bit longer maybe
because my internet is
a bit slow here it doesn't really matter
um let's see okay so now we have our
files in repository
okay this is great but we
yeah i still cannot do a lot here
i can query my local repository
yeah totally fine so i found like
100 results
loading all the frames was well i think
pretty
pretty fast and search was also fast
but i have no clue if the the
results are only any good so let's go to
another notebook plotting
and the first thing i have to say is
there's a
cool library written by andy
rollingson also very active in the
soccer analytics community
and that's one we can use for plotting
so let's see what happens here
just do the imports create function
and you can see that i can just use the
extruder pulse story
should i check this right now oh right
now let's leave for now
okay um unload the data set from the
exterior pole story
um and let's look at some frame and you
can see it's
exactly like the domain model that we
described earlier so it has a frame id
it has a timestamp
it has play corners jersey number and
then the corners on the page
so that's cool let's let's draw just
draw one frame
and it looks like this one and
this we wrote pretty much code already
and this is the first time that we
actually see some results so that's uh
that's cool and
yeah i think it looks good we have the
the black spot is the ball position
um red is let's see the
the home team blue is a home team
register away team okay and now we we
can start actually
doing the fun stuff because we have a
search application service
that i can pass the type of matcher and
we can posit the repository
done and now let's search for it
okay cool so it's still pretty fast
uh result set should i plot it oh okay
as you can see it returns a frame id
with a certain score
and again another frame id another score
let's grab those frames from our data
set
so we have the reference frame and a
result frame
and let's draw those two so the first
one is the reference frame
this is the one that i selected and this
is another one
that our algorithm found
and as you can see well the goal these
are probably goalkeepers
are almost at the same position the ball
is pretty right
there's also a player here to the
side of the page another one here so i
think this one looks pretty
pretty similar we can also do it for
another one
you could can see players are also
pretty much in similar position
um and
yeah i think this is is pretty pretty
good for now this could
help our users
let's go back to the code
and of course i was also able to write
some tests for this
i think we shouldn't go through all this
code right now but
the repository will be made public after
stock so you can just have a look
at how we wrote those tests and um
yeah see how it works and after talk you
can also
of course ask questions about uh how and
why
um i wrote a certain test
okay next step so we're almost there
um so here we saw that we can actually
plot it
um it looks like it makes sense
but we want to have a flask um
on top of it so we can actually
even yeah use for example
a curl or way get or some other
application that can use those
results
so let's have a look again
we import flask um json send file
compress yeah compress is a thing
because the
the frames it's pretty big big json so
we just compress it and send it over
other stuff of course we use our
application server
the service to do the actual search
we have a minecraft metro because we
want to use that one
in this case we use the s3 repository
and we have a serializer that we use to
serialize
an entire data set to to json
and let's see i just want to use the
local
one did i already have it running here
so how can i start it i go to the source
directory
and just run the
an app to run an app i mostly use this
one
i have hot reloading in it so if i
change the source code it will just
reload my server
and i
register some roots so
i have a route to return all frames
within a data set
and i want to return the results
so let's have a look at that
yeah a little support again
data sets in this case my data set id is
one
it's a test i can see that over here
i just have to pause it uh an id to data
set
but doesn't really matter a lot
and i can get the frames
okay wait i have some fancy tool here
okay well i don't have a fancy tool
there
after all uh we can see yeah i have no
clue but it looks
like frames so a lot of data i see frame
id
somewhere between a frame id timestamp
ball position
great for the home team x and i
coordinates
okay it looks great
and question is can we also search
okay so again
i search for um a frame
and get me results with a certain score
um well yeah
i guess we have or
apis already here but still
now we have an an interface to our
algorithm
which is just an uh api endpoint so we
can
i could use i could use in a different
tool
but i still don't have a
visualization on top of this
so i i wrote one um
let's go into into this one and
to be honest this is not the the most
beautiful coat i had to
extract it from a little bit of bigger
application
and i didn't really have time to
to clean this up so it's pretty old code
but
it does the trick and what i did here
uh normally you'd uh need a lot of uh
building tools to build a reactor
application
uh like webpack um and uh node.js and a
lot of stuff
but in this case i'll just load it from
cdn
load react from cdn react dom bible
and what bible does is translate
all this stuff and mostly this theft is
actually
jsx it's all translated into
plain javascript so it's able to to run
it in the browser
and what does it do we have an
application here
go to c2 search that's how we we call it
and first step what we'll do is grab all
the frames
um it stores the frame somewhere and if
the framework stores it will
just render it i'm not really sure if
it's
very interesting to go through all this
react code
um yeah if you want to you can just do
it on your
your own and if you have questions
i will answer this but i think for this
talk i will just
go playing to the result so i can
open this one let's also inspect
what's going over the network
so all our frames are passed from our
back end
it will just return it let's see
a test or all frames are returned
[Music]
so these are the coordinates for all the
home players corners for all
away players and this is our
tool that actually draws them so when i
go through the slider it'll it will go
to the entire match
okay so um here we show that we are able
to
load a data set from
the s3 repository we are able to
stabilize it to json and return it with
our flask application
and next step is to to verify that
uh the integration with the search api
also makes sense so we have a button
here
find situations and you can see
[Music]
it will just load a
request research api
and that one will return or
friends with with the scores
um as you can see they're pretty small
but still wait
let me just make screen a bit bigger
so you can see that the ball is is well
pretty in the same area uh there are
also players
all nearby the the front of the penalty
box
so this one looks pretty similar it's
not pretty weird because it's
almost the same second
but you can see that there are also
other situations and
uh yeah entirely different moments in
the
the match that are also returned
so probably this one and player on the
side of the page
it looks pretty similar
so that's uh i think this results are
pretty good
and the application
that we use for the actual analyst are
is a bit more complex sir i can show it
over here
so it looks pretty similar but we added
some more
configuration here so you can also
tell it that the bold error so the
distance between the ball and the
reference frame and the
result frame is less or more important
so we can do some more filtering there
min or maximum score and the other thing
that we can also do is
tell it to that the attacking positions
are more important than the defending
positions
so you can play around with this one and
in this case we can also export it
so it exports all those moments
in an xml file and you can use it for
further processing in your
analysis tool
okay so now it's it's running on a local
machine
so this is pretty nice so we went from a
notebook
to domain models domain services
application services
um to some infrastructure that helps us
reading files reading files parsing
files
and also serialization of the results
and next step is to actually deploy it
somewhere
and in this case we used heroku for this
and i already
added heroku as a remote
of my git repository of my local git
repository
so how does it work let's see
so i just can create for free
an app on heroku you just have to sign
in is free you don't have to
add any credit card usual information or
whatsoever
you create an app you can use the heroku
tool belt login you have to specify your
login information and you can
connect it to your local repository and
you will get
this remote repository here and the cool
thing about heroku
is that you only have to specify specify
a little bit of information to make it
work so
one important thing is that i have to
specify the runtime
and when i push the data it will make
sure that i have this
particular version of python it also
makes sure that
i have this requirements installed
and it will launch it with g unicorn in
this case
on a certain port and you have to
specify the environment fireball
because heroku can run it on any random
port let's see what happens
just committed some
changes
well let's also have a look at
okay yeah i cheated a bit because i
run this already this morning oh
okay um but here we can see all the
logging from heroku
uh when i push a new version we will see
that it will well i started a new build
and we can see what's going on so it
tells me
it's detecting a python app well in this
case
it didn't detect any change in the
requirements because i already pushed it
it will install some some other stuff
and just have to wait a bit
um yeah compressing it
and it's still the the free dyno and
dino is just another word for server on
my heroku
um uh it's for free after i think it can
only run
like 14 hours a day uh and otherwise you
have to pay like seven dollars a month
so now it released a new version uh i
had to do some testing so already at the
version 22.
and here you can say see that well
it's deployed released it's starting a
new
server so that's great and now let's
have a look at it
okay this is great this is great
so we also have uh debugging information
here
uh of course so what i'm what i did
is i boost a version live
with
a local repository and of course there's
no data there
so let's switch to the s3 repository and
the fun fact about
using the repository pattern is i only
have to change
those two lines and then i switch to
another place where it should get its
data from
use s3 repository
again push to roku
and we can see that a trick is a new
build
let's wait a bit
um yeah
yeah still running so
it's pretty big because i've had numpy
and sci-fi and stuff like that
so it takes a little bit to deploy it
launching okay fingers crossed of course
okay great so now it's working so now we
deployed our application somewhere on
our roku
with a visualization on top of it does
the search also work
yes
okay
so the the repository that will share
um is exactly this repository with
everything included um
yeah the next step that we we did is
we build those uh parts in the domain
so how does a tracking data set look
like
with a frame and at a certain point
and we also have the infrastructure
layer where we have the parsers
and the thing is that we we notice that
a lot of people in sports analytics
world spend a lot of time on building
parsers and figuring out how
yeah how the domain actually looks like
so we decided to
make a package out of it
and let's see
yeah we
we started a pi sport so it's where a
community
where everyone can become better than
applying spot analytics
and as a really everyone has a really
passion for sports analytics
fear and knowledge but uh i think
for me it's really important that we
also create and
encourage maintainable high quality
open source projects so what we did
is build cloppy and
what we did is grab all the parts from
the domain
and the infrastructure and put it in a
separate package
so when i want to build a cool algorithm
i don't have to implement this myself i
can just import it from the library
i can import the password from the
library and
i can actually build directly
my cool matches
so let's have a look at cloppy for a bit
um and again using
[Music]
the mpl soccer library to do some
plotting
[Music]
in this case i load stats boom data
stats boom data
is data where we have all the pass
information
from persons like passers
shorts tackles it's called event data
so on one side you have the tracking
data whereas every player every
uh 20 times a second and you have to
event data
and in this case i use the event data
from
cloppy and statsbomb is another company
that's also providing a lot of open data
which is really cool so you can start
playing around with it
and um yeah what we did
there is also add a lot of information
like in metadata so when i print this
one well it's
barcelona but it also contains
players and there's a lot of stuff going
on there
um so we know a player we know which
team
if it's home playing or not uh
jersey number full name stuff like that
and if he's starting
so if you want to play with soccer data
uh the
yeah you can use the cloppy library to
start with it
um and yeah just play around with it
and one example that i just want to
provide
is oh it's already there
okay
but what we did here is use the library
to plot for every player is heat map
of where he's given where uh
he's giving the most passes so also the
kernel density
estimation you can see um
ramos is mostly playing on the
left side
yeah one thing is i cannot see uh
what's the home goal but you can see per
player
um you know is heat map
um and we also have the
website club the pi sport where you can
also see some more information about how
to work with tracking data
how to of course print the heat map
and some more information we also have a
discord channel
if you have questions about it
and we gathered with a lot of sports
analytics
people there but i'll also share in our
discord
channel yeah for now
um yeah
that's it i hope you enjoyed it i will
share a
repulse story um in discord
and if you have questions or anything
else just let me know
thanks thanks a lot kun that was really
amazing uh
thanks for showing us how to take
something from notebook to
an application level we have some
questions for you
so first we have some on uh
discord juan asked basically about the
initial code
and when you received uh and used a lot
of memory
and uh your first step was to optimize
the code
creating the different classes and
layers um
there how much uh memory the code
used initially and how much you saved
with your change
well with um with the replacing of the
the kernel density estimation and the
nearest neighbor search we went from
uh i think normally it just
used like 203 or not megabytes
yeah for the nearest neighbor
algorithm and we went to about
five or 10 megabytes because it just
did not have to calculate all the
densities
and did not have to build the nearest
neighbor
stuff
but also in original codes uh there was
a lot of
concerting of pandas arrays
and that also use a lot of memory
uh so instead of doing replacing
stuff in place it was just creating
copies all over the place
so when i changed that that already
saved a lot of memory
uh yeah but just getting rid of the
entire um
nearest neighborhood and nearest
neighbor but saved
the most of the memory nice and um yeah
juan says thanks for the answer
uh we have another question from ewing
that's about the web response time
if multiple users are using your
application at the same time
how is that like well that really
depends on where you host it
on the free dyno i'm not really sure how
many
uh processes it can run at the same time
well we might just we can just test it
copy copy linker
i mostly use apache benchmark for it
again to do all concurrent
i think it will be pretty bad in this
case
um any tips for
really doing production style serving
um yes yes
yeah you could go of course serverless
if you want to so it will just kill out
of the box
and in this case you could also add a
caching layer
because the results won't change and
um
yeah i think that's a really easy start
i think
just at caching results are not really
that huge
to keep in memory or to keep the result
on disk
and uh you could just put a engine x or
whatever in front of it
what uh which will do the caching um um
that you use your python server as an
uplink
from the the nginx but that makes the
deployment a bit uh more difficult
but uh i think that that would solve a
lot of problems in the beginning
and then go to kubernetes or whatever
just uh yeah
that's later to do yeah yeah definitely
yeah
and uh really uh highly voted question
from kay
uh that's in the q a you can also take a
look at it yourself
and i'll just phrase this question
exactly as it is
uh i guess frames that are recorded
right
like seconds after each other should be
classified as similar
which is not valuable to the user how do
you prevent that in the code
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah what i did
and um this is a pretty
it's working let's say it's it's not
ugly but it's working
i fixed it in the front end actually
where is it filter
ah this one so this is this
ugly thing so what it does
is it will just check for every result
if it's already seen a result
within 30 frame ids
so if it's within it is just a random
numbers
which you can play around with it um um
yeah i could also i know the frame rate
is 25 i could say
like five seconds at least in between
and maybe even
uh increase it but this could be
something
that you would also
uh wait and like in the search engine
you would just filter them out and
say i will only keep the highest one
within
a certain time frame and drop the rest
and then you don't have to do it in the
front end so that would be
a better solution to just run a step
which
cleans out those results yeah
definitely yeah it's a very very good
question
and finally from our co-chair ruben uh
considering clock copy do you have
practical recommendations
to encourage people to publish open
source
um well
what i've seen in sports analytics is
that a lot of people
started with bringing their own package
to the to the community but i think it's
it's good to start with
contributing to existing packages and
that way you
you will learn uh what you have to do
uh because it's not only throwing some
code into the public and
it's done it's also something i'm still
working on like
documentation uh how to deploy it to
uh or how to publish it to uh
pipey or conda or whatever
so i think the first step is to to find
a package that you like and start
contributing to that one
and talk with the maintainers
yeah just learn what it means to
uh publish it and maintain it so that
would be
definitely the first step cool
okay yeah then we don't have any other
questions not that i can see
and in that case i really like to thank
you for the talk it
was really awesome and let's encourage
the
people who are participating to try it
out and
you'll be there on discord right if
they're stuck yeah definitely i will uh
share a repository in a few and then
you can discuss their uh furthermore
exactly so find the repository link
again on discord and let's give it a go
if you
if you have the energy yes okay
all right then our next session of
course starts
uh like with the talk after lunch
but for now let's give the uh practical
session a go
yup yes great i will switch up the video
here now
and we'll be all available on discord
okay